es reicht wir wollen unseren normales
Leben zurück das fordert Bild diese
Woche das Ende der corona-maßnahmen
abgesehen von der maskenpflicht wie in
unseren Nachbarländern zum Beispiel und
zwar am besten soll das Ganze passieren
bei uns in der Woche der Liebe der Woche
des Valentinstags wann ist der 14
Februar genau könnte keine bessere geben
für die Freedom week aus Liebe zu
Freiheit sozusagen
es reicht gibt uns unser normales Leben
zurück fordert Bild und Millionen
Deutsche sagen so ist es kommt langsam
zur Vernunft seht euch die Zahlen an vor
allem versucht uns nicht zu veräppeln
Regeln runterfahren einfach abschaffen
Stück für Stück an an Dänemark
orientieren schon was Dänemark gemacht
hat die die sich orientiert haben zahlen
runter Maßnahmen runter und nicht immer
noch verschärfen nicht die 2g+ Regelung
das ist umständlich und das hilft
niemanden ab
ich glaube
gefährlicher als Pandemie ist
mittlerweile dass die Leute durch sind
und brauchen wieder ihre Freiheit das
macht doch keinen Sinn im Fußballstadion
vor 10.000 Zuschauer zu spielen die
haben öffentlichen Luft mit der Maske
rumzulaufen oder hier an der Straße
bringen Menschen seehofen Radfahren die
mit Masken in Riss doch sinnlos ist Set
ja
die bevölker schon so verängstigt also
lastet sein mit dem Masten bitte hebt
sie auf die Regel denn längstes klar die
Lage auf den Intensivstationen ist
stabil Omikron ist harmloser als gedacht
die Maßnahmen wirken kaum dagegen und
auch fast alle anderen Länder um uns
herum machen auf
Bild live-chef Klaus Strunz fordert wenn
ich richtig
sehe beginnt die Woche mit dem
Valentinstag also einen großen Tag der
Liebe dann lasst uns doch die nächste
Woche zur freiheitswoche machen in
Deutschland und damit ist er nicht
allein nach diesem wirklich zwei oder
zweieinhalb sehr intensiv und
anstrengenden Jahren für uns alle wird
es einfach Zeit dass wir endlich diese
Maske ablegen dürfen und uns nicht
ständig wieder Gedanken machen müssen
muss ich mich noch testen wo darf ich
hin was muss ich beachten es wird Zeit
und ich freue mich auf diese
Aufbruchstimmung und auf die Positivität
und dass wir endlich wieder alle
zusammen Spaß haben dürfen irgendwann
muss es doch mal gut sein wir müssen
doch nach vorne gehen und dann einfach
mal sagen jetzt leben wir wieder normal
so wie es einfach früher war
Dänemark macht den Anfang vielleicht
zieht Deutschland hinterher wer weiß ich
würde es mir wünschen ja wir wollen
unser normales Leben zurück das sagt
auch Brautmode Unternehmerin Sonja
Katharina Handke aus Köln vor Corona
hatte ich 16 heute noch fünf
Mitarbeiterinnen die Regeln müssen weg
damit die Brautpaare wieder sicher ihre
Hochzeiten planen können bei uns hat
eine Braut 100 Quadratmeter Platz muss
trotzdem Maske tragen und im Restaurant
sitzen alle dicht an dich und
Fitnessstudio Betreiber Harry karkas das
auf unserem Rücken die corona-regeln
ausgetragen werden ist ungerecht die
Kunden sind zu bequem sich für einen
Besuch testen zu lassen gleich Anfang
des Jahres sind uns über 200 Verträge
weggebrochen ich musste schon an meine
rentenrücklagen ran um Miete und
Krankenkasse zu bezahlen und
Automatenaufsteller Thorsten Jabs aus
Delmenhorst die Hotels in denen meine
Snack und Getränkeautomaten stehen haben
durch fehlenden Tourismus kaum Umsatz
bisher überlebte ich mit Krediten und
corona-hilfen wegen der
Rückzahlungsforderung eines Großteils
der Hilfen überlege ich aufzugeben und
Millionen weitere
ja lassen wir hier Menschen zu Wort
kommen die genau dasselbe fordern uns
zugeschaltet ist jetzt
CDU-Bundestagsabgeordnete Jana Schimke
hallo Frau Schimke und ebenfalls der
ex-formel 1 Moderator und
Reisejournalist Kai Böcking hallo
Böcking und last but not und sprechen
wir mit dem Unternehmer Stefan Frenkel
Herr Fränkel sie betreiben vier
exklusive Bowling Lounges in vier
verschiedenen Bundesländern das heißt
die mussten das volle corona-maßnahmen
wirver ertragen vielleicht die erste
Frage direkt an Sie wie sehr wünschen
sie sich den Freedom Day ja also mehr
als alles andere es ist tatsächlich so
dass
wir in vier Bundesländern sind und auch
vier verschiedene Verordnungen haben und
das ist für unser Geschäft natürlich ein
Wahnsinn wir haben über 100.000 Euro für
Hygienemaßnahmen ausgegeben und ja es
wird Zeit dass wir unser normales Leben
zurückbekommen und ein Beispiel in
Hannover am letzten Wochenende hatten
wir von
Freitag bis Sonntag 450 Anrufe für
Reservierung weil eben online nichts
mehr zu reservieren war und wir leider
in Niedersachsen nur jeder zweite Bahn
verkaufen und vermieten dürfen und ja
das sind wahnsinnige Einbußen die wir
haben und wir brauchen unsere Freiheit
zurück und ich beneide unsere Nachbarn
in Dänemark wo ich auch gute
Geschäftskontakte hinhabe und ja es muss
jetzt wieder was passieren und wir
brauchen
unsere Freiheit zurück und unsere Gäste
und unsere Partner sehnen sich danach
Herr Frenkel das sind der ganz
persönliche Gründe auch geschäftliche
Gründe die sie haben sprechen mit Frau
schemke sie ist Politikerin
CDU-Bundestagsabgeordnete sie muss also
abwägen über den Dingen stehen es gibt
ja pro und contra Stimmen warum sagen
auch Sie Herr mit der Freedom week
naja weil ich einfach nah bei den
Menschen bin und weil ich sehe was in
diesem Land los ist ja und ich frage
mich ganz ehrlich was musste noch
geschehen damit wir endlich unser Leben
zurückbekommen wir wissen die
Intensivstationen sind nicht überlastet
wir wissen Omicron ist nicht mehr so
gefährlich wir wissen aber sehr wohl
dass die Kollateralschäden in der
Wirtschaft bei Kindern und Jugendlichen
erheblich sind und ich sage Ihnen
Politik ist auch nur so gut wie sie von
den Menschen akzeptiert und gelebt wird
und was wir im Moment erleben sind
Entscheidungen sind politische
Entscheidungen die dir die mit dem
Lebensgefühl der Menschen mit der
Lebensrealität der Menschen nicht mehr
viel zu tun haben dieses Land ist
einfach was das emotionale angeht
ziemlich am Ende und deswegen glaube ich
müssen wir dringend jetzt auch abrüsten
bei den Maßnahmen und zur Normalität
zurückkehren Herr Böcking was sind denn
ihre ganz persönlichen Gründe die
Freedom week nächste Woche endlich
einzuläuten
ja ich glaube einfach dass wir aufführen
müssen allen Menschen so viel Angst zu
machen ich bin trotz Corona in den
letzten Jahren 200 Tage im Jahr
unterwegs gewesen auf der ganzen Welt
und ich habe einfach festgestellt klar
wir haben alle dieses Problem mit dem
Virus und die Pandemie ist überall aber
es gibt einfach Länder wo man sehr viel
entspannter damit umgeht und da geht es
gar nicht darum dass man da keine Maske
tragen muss oder dass man einreist noch
ein Test vorlegen muss und es geht darum
dass die Menschen einfach nicht so viel
Angst haben in den Bereichen wo sie sich
bewegen dürfen auch frei bewegen und ich
habe immer das Gefühl ich lebe ja in
Bayern dass man immer wenn ich
zurückkomme von der Reise ist wieder
neue Regeln gibt die kein Mensch
versteht die sich ändern wir haben es
gerade wieder heute morgen erlebt bei
uns ändert sich hier in Bayern jetzt
wieder alles es ist wieder 2G wird
abgeschafft es kommt 3G aber nur da in
diesem Bereichen und für mich ist es
einfach so ich habe die Erfahrung
gemacht in den in den letzten Monaten
dass man einfach aufhören muss den
Menschen immer Angst zu machen es ist so
wie es ist und wir wissen alle dass es
keine guten Zeit war aber es muss jetzt
wirklich mal Schluss sein den Menschen
immer noch mehr Angst zu machen drei
Stimmen die für immer mehr Menschen in
diesem Land sprechen die sagen es reicht
gibt uns unser normales Leben zurück
sowie Bild das fordert vielen Dank für
Ihre Meinung danke schön